ونعود الان الى تشييع نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس صالح العاروري في
بيروت ومعنا من طريق الجديده في بيروت
مراسل الجزيره جوني طانيوس جوني ضعنا في
اجواء هذا التشيع وما ابرز الشخصيات من
ابرز الشخصيات التي تشارك فيه
كذلك في الواقع وسيله بعد دقائق قليله من
المفترض ان تبدا الصلاه على جسامين
الشهداء الثلاثه الذين يشيعون هنا في
منطقه الطريق الجديده نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس الشيخ صالح العاروري
والقائد في كتائب القسام عزام الاقرع
وايضا العنصر في حركه حماس محمد الريس
كانت الجثامين قد وصلت قبل اكثر من نصف
ساعه تقريبا الى مسجد الامام علي الذي نقف
نحن في محيطه وكان في استقبالها طبعا حشد
من المواطنين واللاجئين الفلسطينيين في
لبنان وجمهور حركه حماس ومواطنين لبنانيين
بطبيعه الحال صلاه الجنازه من المفترض ان
تبدا بعد هذه الكلمه التي تلقى باسم عائله
الشهيد صالح العاروري وكان سبق هذه الكلمه
طبعا صلاه العصر التي اقيمت بعد وصول
الجثامين هناك حشد كبير من الشخصيات التي
كانت حضرت الى هنا وتحديدا الشخصيات
الفلسطينيه وممثله عن الفصائل الفلسطينيه
المختلفه الى حيط والى الى مسجد الامام
علي من اجل المشاركه في عمليه التشييع
والمشاركه في الصلاه طبعا الجميع هنا في
حال من الغضب حيال هذه العمليه عمليه
الاستهداف التي كانت حصلت قبل يومين في
الضحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت وتم في خلالها
اغتيال الشيخ صالح العاروري وسته اخرين من
بينهم قائدين في كتائب
القسام من المفترض بعد صلاه الجنازه ان
تنقل الجثامين على الاكتاف الى مدافن
الشهداء في منطقه شتيله غير البعيده من
هذه المنطقه طبعا كما نشاهد الاعلام اعلام
الفصائل الفلسطينيه والرايات الفلسطينيه
والاعلام الفلسطينيه تحمل من قبل
المشاركين ومن قبل المشيعين هنا في منطقه
الطريق الجديده كما ذكرت كان هناك مواقف
سياسيه مخ لفه في اليومين الماضيين التي
نددت بعمليه الاغتيال التي قام بها العدو
الاسرائيلي من خلال استهداف مكتب حركه
حماس بعدد من الصواريخ في قلب الضاحيه
الجنوبيه لبيروت طبعا التنديد الابرز على
المستوى اللبناني كان من جانب حزب الله
ويوم امس قال الامين العام لحزب الله ان
جريمه اغتيال صالح العروره هي تطور خطير
لن يمر من دون رد
و وان هذا الرد ات
لا محاله وتوجه نصر الله بالامس الى
الجانب الاسرائيلي بالقول بيننا الميدان
والايام والليالي وكذلك طبعا على المستوى
السياسي كانت هناك طبعا ادانه وتنديد من
قبل رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب مقاطي
الذي قال في بيان ان عمليه اغتيال العروره
في قلب الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت هي جريمه
بكل المواصفات هدفها طور لبنان في النزاع
الاكبر وقال ان لبنان يلتزم القرارات
الدوليه وتحديدا القرار 1700 وواحد الذي
انهى الاعمال القتاليه في عام 2006 وانما
يجب ان يطالب بتنفيذ القرارات الدوليه هو
الجانب الاسرائيلي ولبنان ايضا قرر تقديم
شكوى عاجله امام مجلس الامن بسبب هذه
العمليه التي تمت و وبسبب
اغتيال صالح العرور من خلال هذا الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي في قلب الضاحيه الجنوبيه
لبيروت طبعا اغلبيه او كل الحاضرين هنا
يؤكدون على ان المواجهه مفتوحه مع العدو
الاسرائيلي بعد عمليه
الاغتيال هذه وان عمليه اغتيال صالح
العاروري لا يمكن ان تمر من دون رد هذا ما
اكدت عليه الكلمات التي القيت قبل الجنازه
التي تقام في هذه اللحظات اذا نترقب سويا
بعد صلاه
الجنازه المسيره ومراسم التشيع التي
ستنطلق من هنا شكرا جزيلا جوني تانيوس
مراسلنا من طريق الجديده في
بيروت